ah la vache
ingénieur agronome j'ai commencé mon
parcours en
en thèse
en travaillant sur la vache plus
précisément sur le rumen ce premier
compartiment digestif de du ruminant
un peu plus de 100 litres chez cet
animal et plus précisément encore sur
les microbes qui résident dans le
domaine la prise de conscience de
l'importance de la relation entre
l'animal et ses microbes c'est présenté
à moi comme une évidence d'emblée et ne
m'a jamais quitté depuis pourquoi ça et
bien parce que le ruminant la vache la
chèvre le mouton dépend à 95% pour son
énergie à 80% pour ses protéines de
l'activité microbienne dans le rumaine
l'herbe qui est ingéré et ruminé tombe
dans le rumen c'est de la matière
végétale et sans la contribution des
microbes l'animal ne veut pas en tirer
tous les bénéfices c'est l'exemple
typique d'une symbiose alors je suis
Joël doré directeur de recherche à
l'Institut national de la recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement
je pilote des travaux qui vise à
apporter une meilleure connaissance de
la relation entre l'aliment les microbes
et l'humain pour comprendre comment
fonctionne cette symbiose finalement et
puis j'ai la chance aussi en expert du
microbiote de contribuer à la
coordination du grand projet le
microbiote français le French got qui
vise à recruter 100 000 volontaires en
population française vous pouvez en
faire partie pour caractériser leur
microbiote construit à la référence
nationale et en même temps mettre cette
information en regard des habitudes
alimentaires des modes de vie et de la
santé bien sûr puis je suis aussi
cofondateur et conseil scientifique
auprès de start-up du domaine qui
développe de l'innovation dans des
volets aussi variés que le diagnostic
pour GMT la prévention notamment dans
les maladies du foie pour novo biomes et
ce que l'on appelle la microbiothérapie
ou le transfert de microbiote fécales
pour Matt Pharma
je suis un modeste scientifique et
pourtant pour cette fois je vais vous
dire appelez-moi maître parce que je me
propose ici de me faire l'avocat du
microbiote et ce faisant je fais de vous
Mesdames et Messieurs les jurés d'un
procès dans lequel mon client le
microbiote souhaite faire reconnaître
les agressions dont il a fait l'objet
depuis trois générations humaines alors
qu'il est nous qu'on est lui et que
notre préoccupation au quotidien devrait
être de construire une relation
conviviale et harmonieuse
alors
si je connais bien mon client c'est
qu'il a été mon objet de recherche
depuis mon tout début de carrière il y a
40 ans autant vous dire à ce moment là
on en parlait pas beaucoup c'était
plutôt exotique ça a bien changé
aujourd'hui on sait que le microbiote
est important on sait qu'il nous apporte
un tas de bénéfices et finalement
ma carrière m'a conduit à construire
apporter la connaissance du microbiote
au fil de au fil des années
alors je sais malgré tout que parmi vous
vous êtes nombreux à considérer que mon
client le microbiote fait partie d'une
bande d'agresseur
permettez-moi d'essayer de vous
convaincre que les fonctions qu'il
exerce sont essentiellement des
fonctions protectrices et que d'une
certaine façon c'est potentiellement un
bienfaiteur j'en citerai quatre en un
mon client le microbiote nous aide à
digérer les fibres alimentaires et ce
faisant nous apporte des vitamines des
minéraux des composés des petites
molécules bénéfiques pour le
fonctionnement de nos cellules en deux
mon client le microbiote exerce une
action directe contre la prolifération
des microbes de l'environnement
pensez-y quand vous mangez un morceau de
fromage c'est 100 milliards de microbes
des bactéries des levures des
champignons pas tous amis et pourtant
aucun d'eux n'a de chances de
s'installer dans vos intestins tant que
mon client veille au grain en trois mon
client entretient en permanence la
vigilance de notre système immunitaire
nos défenses naturelles dont on a
vraiment besoin qui exercent cette
fonction délicate de d'intervenir à
chaque fois que quelque chose peut
tourner mal dans l'organisme et qui
pourtant apprennent après la naissance à
reconnaître mon client comme normal en 4
enfin mon client envoie des informations
à travers tout l'organisme vers des
tissus et des organes aussi variés que
le tissu adipeux le foie les poumons le
cœur le cerveau le cerveau
on parle parfois des intestins en disant
c'est le deuxième cerveau pourquoi bien
parce que ils contiennent des neurones
beaucoup de neurones c'est le deuxième
pool de neurones après le cerveau d'en
haut mais aussi on sait qu'il y a une
signalisation qui va du haut vers le bas
qui peut nous causer un petit peu de
souci en termes de transit intestinal
quand le stress est là avec un examen
par exemple mais on sait aujourd'hui
aussi qu'il y a une signalisation qui va
du bas vers le haut on parle d'axe
intestin cerveau et qui fait que mon
client le microbiote contrôle en partie
au moins la perception de satiété après
un repas la sensation de bien-être ou à
l'opposé d'anxiété ou de dépression on
sait même que certains microbes
intestinaux sont capables de produire
des précurseurs de neuromédiateurs comme
la sérotonine l'hormone du bien-être
alors si j'ai la chance finalement de
d'exercer mon métier sur cet objet qui
nous concerne tous puisqu'on est tous
micro bien écosystème et symbiose et
bien pourtant je sais qu'on hérite de
trois générations à travers lesquelles
mon client le microbiote est plus
globalement la symbiose ont été
maltraités et ça a eu deux effets
majeurs le premier effet c'est un
appauvrissement drastique de nos
microbes intestinaux en termes de
diversité et de richesses c'est d'une
certaine façon le voler
occulte de la sixième extinction dont on
parle en pensant un secte poisson
oiseau mammifère ça concerne aussi les
microbes on le mesure formellement en
sciences en recherche en comparant le
microbiote de population rester à
l'écart de la modernité comme des
chasseurs cueilleurs en Afrique ou des
populations indigènes en Amazonie par
comparaison avec nos populations nos
microbiote en population occidentale ce
que l'on observe quand on fait ça c'est
que nous avons perdu en Occident 50% de
la richesse d'espèces bactériennes dans
nos intestins puis le deuxième effet
c'est cette augmentation constante
incontrôlée des maladies chroniques les
grandes pathologies de société moderne
qui font que l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé parle d'épidémie et nous dit
aujourd'hui que une personne sur quatre
sera concernée par au moins une de ces
maladies souvent plusieurs en même temps
d'ici 2025 autant dire demain
allons un peu plus loin si l'on zoome
sur les intestins et bien cette perte de
richesse diversité on la documente dans
les grandes maladies chroniques et à ce
que l'on observe c'est que elle fait
partie de ce contexte de maladies et
puis on a un regard de façon assez
systématique une altération de
paramètres de l'humain c'est la
perméabilité intestinale qui
s'accompagne d'inflammation qui
s'accompagne de stress oxydants qui peut
elle-même altérer davantage encore le
microbiote intestinal on voit bien
comment on peut avoir un cercle vicieux
qui fait qu'on est dans un contexte où
l'on peut basculer dans un état de
symbiose altéré qui sera très compliqué
à restaurer
peut-être vous savez Mesdames et
Messieurs les jurés que 15% d'entre vous
aujourd'hui consultent un généraliste ou
un spécialiste pour des problèmes
intestinaux et que 50% d'entre nous
durant notre vie auront à consulter des
médecins pour pour des problèmes
intestinaux
alors vous allez me dire mais altération
du microbiote intestinal maladie
chronique où est la poule ou est l’œuf
effectivement les travaux initiaux qui
ont été réalisés qui comparent des
patients et des individus en bonne santé
ne nous parlent que d'associations de
corrélation et pas du tout de causalité
la science permet malgré tout d'accéder
à des éléments de causalité à travers le
transfert de microbiote transfert de
microbiote d'humains vers des animaux
des animaux modèles notamment de
patients vers des animaux qu'on élève
sans germe et qui montrent que la
reconstruction d'une symbiose altérée
s'accompagne souvent une reproduction
des symptômes de la maladie transfert de
microbiote de l'humain vers l'humain
cette fois-ci à des fins thérapeutiques
qui montrent que le transfert de
microbiote de sujets en bonne santé vers
des patients permet souvent parfois de
reconstruire une symbiose fonctionnelle
et se faisant de diminuer ou d'éliminer
les symptômes de maladies y compris dans
des contextes de maladies ou le trouble
neuropsychiatrique
alors cependant nos collègues
mathématiciens théoriciens des systèmes
complexes nous disent s'il peut y avoir
un siècle un cercle vicieux qui
s'installe à ce moment-là quel que soit
la source quel que soit le point de
départ de ce cercle vicieux on va
atteindre et peut-être dépasser des
points de bascule et se retrouver dans
un contexte sous le retour à l'état
initial sera potentiellement impossible
pour les fans de changement climatique
finalement selon ton paralysie c'est la
même chose que les boucles de
rétroaction qui nous disent le
réchauffement induit la fonte du
permafrost qui induit la libération de
méthane un gaz à effet de serre qui va
aggraver le réchauffement ou encore le
réchauffement induit la fonte des
calottes glaciaires qui induit la
diminution de l'effet d'albédo
accumulation de l'énergie solaire et
aggravation de réchauffement donc on est
sur des contextes bien connus comment
a-t-on pu en arriver là comment a-t-on
pu à ce point altérer la symbiose entre
l'humain et ses microbes et bien c'est
une question compliquée mais on peut
proposer on peut évoquer pour ne pas
dire invoquer trois possibilités trois
causes la première c'est la modification
les changements de tout ce qui entoure
la naissance ce moment si critique ou le
petit de l'humain va pour la première
fois rencontrer le monde microbien et de
voir développer dans le même temps son
microbiote et son système immunitaire
ses défenses naturelles c'est un moment
de la vie où au-delà du tout à fait
copieux de microbes maternelle qu'on
reçoit à la naissance et bien il faut
qu'il y ait une rencontre avec une
grande diversité de micro-organismes
mais on a petit à petit un peu interdit
cette rencontre le deuxième volet c'est
la transition nutritionnelle ce
changement d'habitude alimentaire qui
fait qu'on a réduit drastiquement notre
rapport de fibres alimentaires et bien
on sait aujourd'hui que le français
moyen consomme autour de 17 g de fibres
par jour alors que la recommandation
d'une nutritionnistes est plutôt de 30 g
et puis avec les fibres avec la matière
végétale vient souvent de la couleur
c'est des polyphénols qui apportent
également des effets bénéfiques puis le
troisième volet c'est l'augmentation de
l'exposition à de la chimie
environnementale à travers la pollution
à travers l'alimentation également avec
les additifs alimentaires une
augmentation d'exposition qui est allée
beaucoup plus vite que ce que ne peut
gérer nos gènes le génome humain et qui
donc expose directement mon client le
microbiote à cette insulte alors sur ces
volets là bien on a simplement entraîné
un retard de développement précoce à mon
client on lui a imposé un jeune forcé et
on l'a tout bonnement intoxiqué
alors mon client bien sûr s'insurge
contre cette situation de maltraitance
et
ce d'autant plus que l'on a les clés
pour faire beaucoup mieux en termes de
gestion de nos microbes et de notre
symbiose tout d'abord quand tout va bien
et bien on a l'alimentation
l'alimentation à travers un apport riche
et diversifié de fibres alimentaires et
de microbes vivants des fibres
alimentaires en richesse et diversité
pourquoi parce que nos microbes
intestinaux ne voient pas arriver des
carottes des choux des noisettes ou des
betteraves non il voit arriver de la
cellulose des xylan des pectines des
amidons résistants chacune de ces
molécules complexes étant la clé d'une
niche écologique qui va d'abord et avant
tout servir un spécialiste un microbe
qui à travers l'évolution à acquis les
compétences pour dégrader une molécule
complexe pour la cellulose un polymère
très simple de glucose en fait il faut
que une bactérie qui la dégrade possède
au moins 20 Gênes pour produire au moins
20 enzymes différents on voit bien que
c'est un spécialiste qui a à qui ces
compétences et qui va défendre son
territoire c'est la même chose pour
l'amidon de la banane ou de la pomme de
terre ce sera un spécialiste ces
spécialistes dégradent des molécules
complexes et nourrissent le reste du
microbiote intestinal en entretenant sa
richesse et sa diversité
et puis dans l'alimentation il y a aussi
d'autres composés qui indirectement vont
agir c'est les acides gras les bonnes
graisses en fait les oméga 3 par exemple
c'est les polyphénols qui donnent la
couleur à tous ces végétaux ou ses
fruits c'est également les minéraux
certaines vitamines qui vont agir sur
les intestins leur robustesse et se
faisant protéger le microbes intestinal
avec quelques adaptations quelques
ajustements de nos habitudes
alimentaires on a la possibilité d'agir
vraiment beaucoup sur notre microbiote
et sur notre symbiose et potentiellement
au-delà comme quand on va le voir et
puis quand les choses vont un peu moins
bien ou quand tout va mal quand on est
dans ce contexte de maladie chronique et
bien le besoin est celui de reconstruire
la symbiose humain microbes et mon
client devient à ce moment-là une
ressource c'est c'est lui qui va pouvoir
permettre de reconstruire effectivement
le plus bel exemple et que le transfert
de microbiote fécales entre aujourd'hui
dans la pratique médicale et sauve des
vies tous les jours qui aurait parié que
reconstruire la symbiose par le
transfert de microbiote allait pouvoir
aider des patients à mieux gérer leur
diabète leur rectocolite hémorragique
leur maladie hépatique plus ou moins
sévères ou même des troubles
neurologiques comme l'autisme ou la
dépression qui aurait parié que le
microbiote intestinal
avec le transfert de microbottes allait
permettre d'accompagner le traitement de
patients pour un cancer non seulement en
diminuant les effets secondaires du
traitement mais également
potentiellement en augmentant leur
efficacité
alors peut-être que vous me direz comme
mes enfants qui sont grands aujourd'hui
ma génération a tout autant maltraité la
planète que nos microbiote et l'urgence
aujourd'hui est peut-être tout autant
sinon plus de faire mieux en terme de
gestion de notre incidence sur la
planète que sur nos microbiote et la ce
qui me ce qui me rassure ce qui me
console à titre personnel et
professionnel c'est que je sais que plus
on fera pour mieux nourrir nos
microbiote plus on fera pour mieux gérer
notre symbiose mais en plus on fera pour
la planète pour diminuer notre impact
sur la perte de diversité et sur
la résistance et la résilience des
systèmes vivants
alors mon client c'est cousins en fait
les cousins de mon client les microbes
sont sur la planète depuis 3,5 milliards
d'années nous humains ou moussapiens ou
homo sapiens microbien ça devrait-on
dire je pense qu'on se comprend
maintenant
nous sommes arrivés il y a 300000 ans
autant dire qu'on a écrit les quelques
lignes les quelques dernières lignes de
la dernière page du livre de l'histoire
de la planète et parce que je peux dire
c'est que les microbes n'auront pas
besoin des humains pour rester sur terre
autrement dit mon client et
[Musique]
sans nous là ils s'en sortira très bien
comme il l'a toujours fait alors que
nous sans mon client on aura beaucoup
plus de mal c'est peut-être même peine
perdu donc autant accepter le fait que
ce sont nos alliés pour l'humain et la
planète vous m'avez écouté peut-être
m'aurez vous entendu peut-être me
direz-vous plus jamais tous les microbes
sont dangereux ou encore les
nouveaux-nés les bébés ne doivent
surtout pas rencontrer le monde
microbien ou encore
microbes et cerveau rien à voir non je
pense que ce sont vraiment nos alliés
j'espère vous en avoir convaincu
Mesdames et Messieurs les jurés
permettez-moi de vous adresser mes
salutations symbiotiques et de vous
inviter à mettre un petit peu plus de
végétal de couleur de ferment de bonne
graisses et peut-être un peu moins
d'animal de raffiner de chimie dans vos
assiettes car ce sera l'humain et tout
son environnement qui en bénéficieront
si la question est et sans moi
Martinez moi de vous poser la question
et sans eux merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]